visse ich mache aktive community es aber
bei euch ist einfach so er übertreibt
einfach maslow ich habe letztes spiel
mit einem pferd gespielt das sieht
vielleicht auf den ersten blick aus wie
ein zebra ist es auch für lange ich okay
vielleicht war es ein zebra und vier
minuten nachdem das video online war gab
es das pferd bei akinator
ich war kurz davor mich umzubringen auch
wenn wir sie wieder auf der website sind
sehen wir luca wurde gespielt vitello
wurde gespielt weil uwe oder gespielt
was sagt ihr dazu
immer wenn ich irgendetwas in die kamera
halte ist es fünf minuten später bei
akinator
geht doch mal raus spielen anstatt meine
scheiße da einzureichen es ist gerade
neun toren ich hab grad mit kaffee
geklettert und jetzt habe ich hier ein
taschentuch womit ich den tatort weg
gemacht habe
das ist doch auch wieder gleich bei
akinator das kann auch nicht sagen ihr
seid wahnsinnig aber wir gehen wir
erstmal unser alter ja ein und versuchen
jetzt einfach mal an irgendeine person
zu denken
wir nehmen wir dann da ich kann ja mal
schauen wie oft das pferd chantal jetzt
schon gespielt wurde
ich rede wie so ein langsamer typ ja
meine figur ist durch youtube berühmt
geworden nein sie ist kein lex player
kann stand teil auf zwei beinen laufen
spielte eine figur bei psg
fatal ist tatsächlich ein französischer
name oder bis der die figuren
schäferhund
an den du bist ein schieber ihn ohne
nein meine figur ist kein schäferhund
fakt ist hier der markt eigentlich cool
wegrutschen mit meinem stuhl aber ich
war zu langsam
nochmal bagdad amara de
ja meine figuren kraft dann nein meine
figur ist nicht als holz es ist ein
elektronisches tier aber ich würde mal
sagen ja drehte helwig heute ist sie
sagen straße auf
da gibt's ein ferner wer kennt es nicht
das tolle fährt aus der sesamstraße auch
das ist so prof ich habe gerade mal bei
amazon geschaut und es gibt tatsächlich
das sesamstraße fährt zu kaufen
wien süß ist das bitte die sind alle
uninteressant diesen alone interessant
da ist das pferd das gut gelaunt aber
tollpatschige fährt aus der sesamstraße
hat immer hunger es hat immer oh nein
luca 30 zusammen ich darf nicht noch
mehr geld für stofftiere ausgeben
nein meine figur tritt also nicht in der
dammstraße auf meine figur ist auch
keine hohen ja meine figur sein pferd
eigentlich ist schon teil ii an zebra
wir steht zu höherer kontrast das zebra
fällt mir gerade chinas und mix richtig
es ist schon toll
das ist ein fucking kleinstadt wisst ihr
3800 ist jetzt im vergleich zu meinen
hunderttausend gespielten malen echt
nicht so viel in relativität in relation
zu meiner gespielten anteil oder zuko
ladies gespielte anti nato ist es echt
nicht so viel aber wenn ihr euch mal
überlegt dass das video von dem pferd
gerade mal zwei tage alt ist und ich
nichts über das pferd akinator gesagt
habe sondern einfach nur ihr von euch
auf das pferd akinator eingereicht habt
und ihr in eurer community das schon
3842 gespielt hat
dann klicke ich wieder auf die
startseite von akinator dann sehe ich
wieder chantal wurde gespielt chantal
wurde gespielt und kollege wurde
gespielt
ich glaube es gibt die webs es gibt kein
einziges mal aktualisieren ohne dass
sachen von mir irgendwie in diesen
letzten zehn spielen spielen stehen
spiele
okay ich habe gerade eine ganz gute idee
und zwar den pullover hier den ich
gerade an habe ist ein pullover
ich habe ja gesagt dass mein merchandise
ein bisschen was neues werden soll weil
das meiste merchandise ist bisher
einfach nur drauf gedruckt was natürlich
bei vielen stoff war nicht anders geht
aber hier ist es halt so dass wir hier
so ein pullover gemacht haben ohne
kapuze wollte ich so ganz schlicht sein
pullover macht man damit halt drauf
sticken lassen unterkomponenten noch
sein label dran wo luca draufsteht ins
hintere reihe 3
das hier haben wir auch noch geplant das
ist so gut wie ganz normal also so
einfach wie das smiley der gut luca dass
du durch den pulli durch spricht einfach
für kapuzenpullover oder halt darauf
gedruckt ist dass es nämlich nicht cool
aus mitten drauf gestickt und wir haben
auch überall hinten drin
es kriegt das ja grad nicht hin wir
wollten halt nicht so ein blödes ja das
ist medium und hergestellt in italien
und so da drin haben sondern das ist
quasi jetzt so steht da hinten
ich bin ruhig mal wir haben vielleicht
sogar nützen wenn ihr die wollt ich weiß
nicht ich habe davon über ein paar
machen lassen aber ich weiß nicht
findet ihr die gut ich bin selber ja
kein mensch erzieht man eigentlich eine
mütze auf ich habe überhaupt kein plan
dass man ich fühle mich wie einen
kapitän das sind halt gerade erst mal 37
designs die ich im kopf habe von denen
kommen aber erst mal auf 5 in den shop
also wir haben total viele ideen aber
der shop geht am ersten zwölfter online
luca - shop.de das soll kein werbevideo
sein das heißt wir machen weiter mit
akinator wieso habe ich überhaupt jetzt
von den ganzen pullovern hier also hier
ich habe diesen rover hier gerade an mit
dem smiley und den habe ich gestern
schon auf install angepasst und da meint
einige drohten wird die rückbank im auto
nein meine figur geschnittenen nicht aus
holz nein sie kauft nicht bei lidl ein
nein sie kommen nicht aus dem warrior
cats universum jahr sie steht ein
komplettes
ich glaube es gibt mittlerweile so viele
sachen von mir bei akinator dass es
unglaublich schwer ist warum spiele ich
das überhaupt die ganze zeit nein sie
ist keine reguläre ja sie gehört
kontrakten nein sie
spielt deine figur beim
geschlechtsverkehr eine große rolle
noch nicht nein du deine figur schon mal
verletzten nein oder nicht würde das mit
luca zu tun ja seine figur bleiben
nein ich denke ein konkretes tisch wird
attackiert und geschlagen von konkreter
ich sag mal einfach ja mein tisch wurde
auch schon 58 mal gespielt warum warum
seid ihr bescheuert sollte gerade
einfach so dass wir beiden weiß liebe
wenn man so einen cut und dann ist
wirklich so direkt das video vorbei dass
man nicht am ende noch so sieben minuten
lag aber ich möchte das video mit seid
ihr bescheuert mich wenn ich kann nicht
mehr reden